because of covet my son's been swimming
a lot already has this uh
swim coach he's getting really good at
swimming
and uh because he's in the chlorine it
gives them a rash
so the school called the s'mores okay uh
tiger has a rash he won't stop itching
it we're worried
am i cool do you guys have a nurse right
it's a [ __ ] school
yeah send them to the nurse office tell
them put on some anti-itch cream or
lotion and help them out
they're like because they're covered we
can't touch the kids you got to come do
it
so i had to take my ass up to walgreens
buy some anti-itch cream
drive up there so i drive up put on
tiger
and then i'm leaving and i'm like on my
phone i look up and then
there it's so cute it's like they have
like the fence
and there's like this much gap and i
just see
[ __ ] 15 heads and i can see tiger
because he's telling everyone about my
car
and i start and gets all loud i hear him
go i bro my way he was papa drive fast
drive fast for my friends i see him
looking when i'm pulling up
elementary school you feel good what
else is exhausting as we do elf on the
shelf you guys know what that is
that's where you like the shelf
everybody else they watch you so
the way you do it with kids is you say
you know if you're the elf on the shelf
is in the house right now for christmas
and he reports back to santa yeah if
you're bad that elf's gonna let santa
know
so we have a little mailbox and tiger
like writes stuff there once puts in the
mailbox
got it but then also right like he was
mean to me yesterday
hope like at the end of the day i'm like
dude you know the elf's watching he's
like oh you're right
so hold on like sorry i was mean to my
dad and then
tossing the thing so he went but you
gotta move the elves around so you gotta
make it seem like when he goes to bed
he helps move around every day every
every night it's a beast
so he goes to bed i'm like trying to
figure out and i always set up cool [ __ ]
so i have him hanging off the tv
so i have one hanging off the tv i put a
rope down the other one's hanging upside
down and then you leave a note for him
oh yeah that's awesome yeah look at you
getting all creative but now it's like
this
oh dude i might have ideas
so he woke up and they're just both on
the [ __ ] table just sitting there
with their arms crossed like this
with a letter said be nice to your dad
hey so this is scary as [ __ ] um a woman
in maryland
was in her apartment it looks like it's
a studio apartment
you kind of look around and you see the
entire thing she's recording a tick tock
video
like a dance video she's literally just
vibing in a room
making a video for tick tock when
suddenly she hears something
like right by her side next to her
like balcony door and a man opens it up
there's a man that's been kind of like
watching her for a few days
in her neighborhood walk back and forth
and then he broke into
her apartment while she's filming this
ticket
through the front door it does look like
that's the door to her balcony
so he got onto the balcony opened it up
she caught it on camera she runs out is
she a kid
uh no she is a woman she is a young
person
she looks like a little kid no she
doesn't she doesn't oh
but yeah this is the video i can tell by
a body type she
that's a little kid yeah she got a kiss
buddy
it's a terrible video
who are you who are you please get off
please get out no please get out
are you sure yes who are you
please get out of my apartment right now
please get out of my apartment right why
would you talk that much i would just
bail yeah i would just run yeah get out
holy [ __ ] and that's her balcony
she need to do laundry
please jesus
christ so she ends up calling the police
the police comes and they
arrest him i think he's currently being
held on bond but he had a bunch of other
[ __ ] that he was arrested for did you
see do you see homeboy that broke into
uh
oh dion demar derozan yeah but he was
there to break it because he's uh kylie
jenner yeah
he was there to scout out kylie jenner's
place and he broke into india
arrested him no he broke into hers
or his because he thought it was kylie
jenner she's trying to get
and she's getting a restraining order
against him now but the moral was
that dude was like hey bro like you know
damaris from compton i don't know why he
didn't whip his ass
well he the guy was like yo he he tried
to reason with him he's like hey man i
was just
i
he's so ugly
man let's jump yeah i swear that was a
kid that's not a grown ass
oh no that's the guy that broke in the
girl's apartment yeah
and that's the thing he said are we
friends yeah he said are we friends
she's like
she said no he said are you sure jesus
christ
that's her that's her that's her why she
looks so crazy right there i know she
looks different
edition and then do they have the
picture of the
tried breaking into kylie jenner's house
well demarco rose tomorrow
yeah demarco the more demarco tomorrow
there it is
derozan breaking is right here no not
images if you type in breaking
and then go to news not images
confront it nah yeah because the dude
was in his kid's room
yeah he was like well that's what you
but the more
that happens he should have knocked him
out no i don't have a picture yet though
yeah you really get something
he goes i grew up in california i've
been through
worse no [ __ ] upset he's lucky
uh he didn't beat the show that guy i
know
damn it's crazy how they would he broke
into the wrong house
yeah now what this was here now uh he
said look he said
he was trying to get into college kylie
jenner's house but made a mistake
eventually the man was eventually
arrested and has been charged with one
count of phillip
telling me but it's like so you put a
restraining order
it was the thing well she has a bunch of
security i think it's more of a legal
thing so
i think like if he goes within a certain
amount of distance he's going to be
arrested right
because then it becomes a are security
felony
that's him no well this is the same name
so i don't know if it's actually him
but justin bieber i was like demar why
you beat this [ __ ]
yeah how do you not beat the [ __ ] up no
she's about to say it don't worry kylie
can take him
clearly that's the wrong guy yeah but
i'm man much love to that girl
i'm sorry that that happened to her i'd
have been what else you got yeah
papa i don't even want any of that to go
let me ask you a question how long are
you pretending i can take slices home
i'm not taking a slices home guaranteed
first of all i'm cutting you off
why i wonder why uh i don't we both have
three slices no
i'm telling you what i'm cutting you off
from what you do food
i'm cutting you off yeah out of my life
when it comes to food you're done wait
why why because we like the same [ __ ]
and i'm sitting here like we're supposed
to be rocking this diet yes i'm ready
i'm like
oh you went already like because you
know he fighting ready
but this fool was like yo you getting
the biscuits and gravy dogs i heard it
and i'm like
well [ __ ] brenda getting the biscuits
and great what you doing exactly
i know you enabled me so i gotta i gotta
split the road dawg oh [ __ ] but we like
the same [ __ ] like you're
some beyonce you're kelly rowland
you were danny's child that's where i'm
at right dude that's where i'm at well
let them know i ain't doing no more
talking no more because every time i
seem to talk about it you mute i get
i'm mute i'm just working you working
i'm just worried you got to say to that
hey man we like to say that
good luck this [ __ ] good luck see you
good luck
when we're on the road he's nice wait
wait wait till we get to uh
well i don't know palm beach i don't
know how the food is there wait till we
get into the chicken
sand uh sam san marcos san marcos texas
20 minutes away from austin
oh you did the reason that's my city
austin city that's my crib that's his
crib
i know all the good food spots
everything your you and me are going to
chow down
and then i'll i'll i'll find one of
those delivery services
or door dad you ain't doing that i'll
find one of those delivery services
where they'll bring the wheels for you
oh really while the rest of us are
[ __ ] lit at the restaurants
you're just going to order your food and
eat at the house kill it and then i'm
gonna take my shirt off
when i get these [ __ ] abs i know it
would be nice is it worth it though
are you taking a shirt does it work hold
on worth it to give up this delicious
food yeah [ __ ] because she was
making fun of my snoring
oh what
yeah i get it all the time there was a
picture uh they took for christmas oh
yeah tell them before we get into this
you want to tell people why you got the
man bun oh yeah we're very
important to talk about that i don't
know
i didn't have it fly as [ __ ] really
just i mean am i a premier league soccer
player i don't know
right yeah i thought you was joking am i
gonna go on love island at uk
i don't know okay i don't know are you
serious but here's the
thing no you know what i was rocking
that mullet but that was just uh that
was just
the transition to get to the man bikes
my friends i need my hair to get longer
i heard that too and my hair to get
longer
and then a few nights ago i the mun band
was the
was the plan for quite some time we just
needed to take time to grow out
but then the other night i was chilling
with my girl yeah and i uh was like oh
can you uh put my
hair up because it's always in my face
i'm wearing a hat she's like you know
you wear a hat
every [ __ ] show like you're always
wearing hats you got good hair like you
know i just don't feel like doing i
don't know what to do and i get this
[ __ ] weird mullet
she's like yeah that's cool can i be
honest i'm like yeah what's up she goes
i [ __ ] hate your hair
that's lovely but really i can't stand
them
we're going to be doing this all the
time yeah i saw the email you saw the
emotion i can't do that now
dude all the [ __ ] takes it out
yeah watch tv and then he'll have his
hair like regular then a commercial
break is right here and everything like
he's like this
what the hell bro like hey guys
are you good at remembering people's
names like celebrities
literally terrible terrible literally
i'm the worst i'm good with faces
yes faces you're really good at names
terrible terrible names
i i can watch a whole season like dude
whatever
yellowstone i can't damn it i only know
rip game of thrones i don't know
anybody's name
i don't know what it is any character on
the fantasy i don't know
i couldn't tell you and you watch it
like couldn't tell you religious i don't
know why it never sticks with me
what about you do you remember people
names yeah i remember names and i
remember
birthdays oddly enough what that's weird
you had birthdays
yeah you told me like one time and i'm
pretty man i'm bad oh it was justin's
birthday yesterday
no it has to be like i have to be like
justin when's your birthday and he has
to give me the exact date
and then it's locked in my head the
shelf going oh
[ __ ] man last i panicked uh last night
because
i fell asleep watching fancy island i'm
like hey put these [ __ ] love island
love island i always call it fantasy
fantasy island is that scary that came
out oh that's right
with uh your girl maggie yeah not a
great movie
not a great movie but uh so i i got lazy
because i usually do all the school [ __ ]
and i just put them in these two like
plants and he came down he's like
yeah there's the house like oh damn
they're around they just decided to be
out like this huh
yeah and it was like not eventful at all
nothing at all he was like all right
i [ __ ] up [ __ ] up i [ __ ] up keep
getting creative man yeah you'll be
surprised
you got this i was tired though you got
a big ass you got a big ass uh
castle so figure it out you know you
ever seen a real castle
i haven't been to the uk oh the house is
not a castle oh have you ever seen a
real castle
like the guys see those ones what's
those ones uh where they do the jousting
are you telling yeah yeah yeah
we seen the castle ones in salt lake the
mormons that's not a catch warmer tough
castle
that's very temple that'd be a church
that's the mormon temple ctr choose the
right
oh that's what they dude medieval times
you've been there oh yeah a bunch i've
never been
i've always wanted to go no i don't i
don't enjoy it anymore
when i was a kid i did but i went i went
like probably five years ago me my girl
went on this double date there
but it reminds me of that uh horrible
idea by the way yeah that's awful
but it's a cable guy when he goes there
oh yeah
and they're eating the food he goes hey
can i get a fork and knife she's all
dude we don't have forks and knife hints
medieval times he goes but you have diet
coke
he goes i got listen dude i got a lot of
tables man
but you had diet coke dude that movie
was good [ __ ] yeah
great movie